the OPEC oil producing countries and
their allies have agreed to slash their
output over the coming months at a
meeting in Vienna OPEC plus which also
includes Russia decided to reduce
production by 2 million barrels per day
the move aims to support oil prices
which have fallen by 30 percent since
June U.S President Joe Biden though says
he's disappointed by the decision which
he's called short-sighted
well let's discuss this further with
Carol nachler who is CEO of crystal
energy thanks a lot for joining us on DW
business this decision by OPEC plus is
going to come as a blow to countries
already struggling with their energy
costs isn't it
well if you go to look at the number two
million barrels a day literally that is
definitely a blow to a market which has
been struggling with high prices but
actually Market observers understand
that's not going to be the actual 2
million dollars a day taken out of the
market because OPEC and its allies in
OPEC plus most of them have been
producing below the quota allocated to
them so in reality the two million
barrels a day would translate into less
than one million barrels a day of
barrels taken out of the market I'm not
trying to downplay the significance of
that among it's not as bad as 2 million
barrels a day but we're seeing already
upward pressure on oil prices which is
already bad news to energy consumers
around the world
yes Americans are particularly going to
see it at their petrol pumps aren't they
and President Biden has said that uh
he's disappointed by this decision he's
called it short-sighted is the US going
to have to act in some way in response
to this
well definitely politically speaking the
U.S is not happy with uh was a decision
I don't want to say the U.S because the
U.S is also the world's largest oil
producer so in that respect high oil
prices can also benefit the U.S to a
certain extent but politically speaking
because we are heading towards midterm
elections in a month's time that is not
good news because high oil prices affect
the popularity of the current president
and his administration how did how the
US were react I'm not quite sure how can
they react in the short term but one of
the possible scenarios is that they will
reactivate the Norfolk bill which was
usually discussed earlier this year and
which would qualify OPEC as a cartel and
there will be consequences legal
consequences but beyond that there will
be mainly political developments which
you are unlikely to guess at this stage
I think with OPEC plus is that Russia is
at the table along with OPEC so is there
anything that we should read into
Russia's involvement here because it
does stand to gain strategically doesn't
it from this decision
Russia is an important player with an
optic plus and it's actually even more
important for the longevity and the
influence of The Producers group and it
is the second largest producer after
Saudi Arabia so definitely it has an
important influence on the group which
is also showing a clear support to
Russia and by putting upward pressure on
prices that by itself is a move to
support Russian oil production and
Russian economy just at a time when
Western powers are considering to put a
price cap on Russian oil exports
okay Karen knuckler from crystal energy
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to us on DW business